bah
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
hu
[Musique]
nous voici dans la cour de la ferme ou
blanche est la petite poule vient de
trouver quelque chose qui brille
[Musique]
pendant ce temps dans la forêt
le coq marche de plus en plus lentement
[Musique]
à nuiton
oh
mon
[Musique]
oh
je suis fatigué qu'à l'aventuré
ouais ouais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
encore que ce passe-t-il donc pourquoi
tout ce bruit qui es tu je suis le coq
de la ferme qui est près de belette
ville
tiens c'est la première fois que je vois
un coq et pourtant j'ai entendu parler
de toi par mal à me piller évidemment
moi aussi c'est la première fois que je
vois une chouette je n'ai jamais eu
l'occasion de sortir de la ferme
si je suis parti c'est parce que le
fermier vient d'acheter un jeune coq on
le regardait tout le temps on parlait
trop de mon père cela a fini par me
mettre la puce à la crête et je me sens
danger or comme je te comprends c'est
incroyable comme les hommes sont ingrats
quand leurs vieux serviteur ne peuvent
plus les servir
ils les mangent enfin ceci n'est pas une
raison pour réveiller les chouettes à
des heures pareil de toute façon un
conseil ne jamais passer la nuit sous un
arbre à cause du renard et demander
asile un animal compréhensifs
oh oui madame la chouette
merci beaucoup le chemin devient de plus
en plus étroits
il fait encore sombre de temps en temps
une petite clairière apparaît entre deux
énormes chaîne
le jour se lève
la forêt sévère voyons voyons voyons
commençons par ainsi dans notre famille
le champ commence toujours par un si si
si si si qui chante faux si je suis au
fusil c'est pas possible tu le fais
exprès fifi ne comprend décidément rien
à la musique que papa merle se donne
tant de mal à lui apprendre
celui ci use de son parapluie mais
l'émotion fait oublier à fifi il est à
merlaut bien élevé et c'est inadmissible
jo est très fâché ces jeunes quel manque
d'éducation tout à peine croyable mais à
quoi bon penser avec cette belle journée
qui s'annonce et la forêt et jo le cac
par découvrir la forêt
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]